Hey youtubers it’s charlie and arrow finally
introduced nyssa al ghul and filled in a lot
of backstory for several of the characters.
Bonus shout out to doctor who fans because
alex kingston came back too.
So there’s a bunch of Arrow news and Flash
news that I have in addition to my review.
So I’ll include all the flash stuff in a
separate video I’m posting tomorrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
I’ll add all the arrow related news after
my review.
Careful for spoilers from tonight’s episode.
Let’s start with our top 5 moments.
Number 5 - Moira VS Brother Blood.
In an episode all about venom it seemed like
Moria was the most dangerous snake.
Their big confrontation came right after oliver
and felicity got done talking about fangs
and throughout the episode Moira had this
lionel luthor look on her face.
If you didn’t watch smallville.
He was the nicest bad guy in the world.
It’s easier to understand why Merlin would
have been someone she was attracted too.
The good thing about her taking on brother
blood is that he’ll have to defend against
her and team arrow at the same time.
Pending whatever Slade does to quote unquote
take care of it.
Number 4 - Felicity tells Oliver about Thea.
This was a meta moment that Stephen Amell
had been teasing.
He said that felicity would get some backstory
in this episode.
And when she explained thea to oliver she
talked about her father leaving and filled
in some really critical information about
why she is the way she is.
Emily Bett is awesome, mostly when she and
Stephen Amell are in a scene together.
Oliver’s reaction was really good too.
If you didn’t catch it, when he went up
to the podium that read Queen for Mayor it
was a huge shoutout to the comic books.
The Green Arrow became the mayor of the city.
I keep expecting Merlin to appear in the background
every time they say his name.
Number 3 - Canary & Nyssa ship.
They kind of teased us with that line ‘the
child of rashe al ghul’ awaits your return.
I thought it might have been a sexual relationship,
but they wasted no time in answering that
question.
Think of Nyssa as the oliver of that relationship
and sara as the felicity.
Be sure to give the arrow writers a high five
for including some real diversity in the dc
universe.
Lesbian and Bisexual characters aren’t new
to the comics, but it’s not something male
driven comic book tv shows do very often.
I thought it was interesting that nyssa released
the canary from the league.
I thought that only rashe al ghul could do
that.
And when he does it it’s usually by chopping
you in half.
Number 2 - Slade steps into the ring.
Manu Bennett has been such a post-credits
character this season.
It’s like all his biggest scenes have been
in the last 3 minutes of each episode.
His comment, “i’ll take care of it.
Makes it sound like he’s finally going to
confront team arrow as deathstroke.
It feels like he’ll reveal himself to oliver
as slade after he fights them as deathstroke.
It’s a classic villain reveal.
I wonder who this mystery assasin is? which
leads to, Oh shit, it’s that guy I stabbed
in the eye and left for dead six years ago.
Number 1 - The emerald archer versus the heir
to the demon..
Best fight this season hands down.
It was like they were trying to see who could
out arrow each other.
I guess archery is a big deal in the league.
First there’s merlin, then oliver, now nyssa.
Even the canary is a deadshot with oliver’s
bow.
I really liked Katrina Law as nyssa in the
episode, hopefully she’ll come back in a
future episode.
Honorable mention goes to the car chase scene.
Oliver vs nyssa was the best fight of the
episode, but the car chase was the best stunt.
I like how the canary screamed out as if she
were doing the comic book version of her canary
cry.
Let me know what your favorite moment was.
Seeing Nyssa, seeing nyssa and the canary.
I saw a hashtag on twitter that said syssa.
Or was it the big fight scene.
For me it was definitely the fight scene.
My favorite character moment was felicity
and oliver though.
They’re so good togeher on screen you could
almost forget it a show about comic book characters.
Although I have to give a shout out to caity
lotz for giving stephen amell a run for his
money on the salmon ladders.
Overall I loved the episode.
I actually gave it an A just because it gave
us so much story and still had some amazing
action scenes and made us want to cry a little.
I didn’t cry, but everytime felicity cries
I almost want to cry just because her character
is so sympathetic.
High fives to emily bett for making everyone
cry.
I’m still not digging laurel’s arc.
Sassy sisters was not fun to watch, I like
watching evil characters be evil, like slade
getting ready to kick some ass.
But I can’t stand watching good characters
be awful to each other.
I’m not a big fan of depressing melodrama
either, so watching laurel slowly flush her
life down the toilet has not been fun.
The show does do a good job of surprising
you.
I geniunely belived sara was going to kill
herself and jump start the laurel black canary
arc.
But then remembered all the birds of prey
talk the writers were doing last week.
So now it’s time for big arrow news and
things that are coming up.
Careful for spoilers from the rest of the
season.
Starting where we’re at, Sara is back for
good now and part of the arrowcave.
It’s starting to get crowded with Roy in
there too now.
It’s going to be a salmon ladder party.
Starting next week with episode 14 and extending
to episode 18 it’s really a villain’s
arc on arrow.
The comic book reference used to describe
it was Villains United.
That includes a public appearance from deathstroke,
a real deal suicide squad and the birds of
prey.
16 will be the suicide squad episode and 17
will be the birds of prey episode.
So you can see how as the villains stakes
rise, a group of heroes has to come help team
arrow.
In related news, I told you I’m doing a
special video for the flash.
I’ll probably post that tomorrow in addition
to my next Q&A video.
So ask me as many questions as you like.
Right Now click here to get that flash video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
the video.
And click here for last week’s arrow.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!